this one this is fantastic news ladies
and gentlemen from variety rich men
north of Richmond debuts at number one
as Oliver Anthony makes Billboard Chart
history
yo this is Richmond north of Richmond
debuting at number one on the Billboard
Hot 100 chart making the singer
songwriter the first artist ever to
notch the achievement with no prior
chart history in any form
he is the sixth artist in Billboard
Chart history to debut a first solo Hot
100 entry at number one following Zayn
Bauer Carrie Underwood Fantasia and Clay
Aiken and Richmond north of Richmond is
the first solo written Hot Hot 100
number one since 2020's heat Waves by
glass animals which top the charts for
five weeks in March and April of 2022.
it was widely shed in line along with a
video of the beard country folk singer
etc etc here we go what do they say
17.5 million streams and 147
000 downloads in the tracking week
ending August 17th per lemonade a
YouTube video of the song has 30 million
views to date which means he will likely
be number one next week as well uh
here's what I gotta say to y'all go to
iTunes buy the song give them the dollar
one down one purchase for a dollar
counts as 150 streams if he gets I think
he needs 150 million streams and it
looks like he's already got 30 plus 147
000 downloads so multiply that by 150.
if he gets 1 million downloads he will
be platinum let's let's let's do what we
can I think I think rich men north of
Richmond should be platinum I'll tell
you why I'm not a country guy never been
a big country guy but anything that
advances independent culture challenging
the corporate machine pushing back on
Hollywood and these sick record labels
and the entertainment industry
needs to succeed
and that's why I mean just seeing the
success of this song
the fairs of Bud Light failures of
Target the success of sound of Freedom
ladies and gentlemen this is changing
the culture and winning the culture war
and they know it that's why they're
getting so desperate and angry as they
drown they will start violently
thrashing about and you know what they
say when you're trying to rescue someone
who's drowning not that we should
figuratively rescue companies that are
failing but if you try to rescue them
they'll drag you down with them you got
to be careful about the the massive
multinational corporations in the
entertainment industry and their creepy
predilections and the weird things they
promote as they lose power they will
become angry and violent and splash
fervently in desperation this means
you're going to see more laws being
lobbied to ban the things that we're
doing they're going to say here's what
they're going to do they're gonna say
well we can't allow these songs to
succeed because it's anti-union because
it goes where's the music Union you know
where's BMI or asgap or whatever and
they're going to claim that this is a
threat because you know it's going to
allow exploitation blah blah blah
they're losing
I'm having a good day yeah I think it's
cool I like when things just organically
happen I'm sort of I'm not a
particularly like musical person anyways
but so often I feel like the songs that
are popular right now are just developed
in the machine for the machine to
benefit the machine and it's cool to see
someone else do something and it have
such a big response I have a confession
to make I actually so I've read the
lyrics but I've actually not listened to
the song yet but I um I tend to be a
little bit uh apprehensive about stuff
like that for exactly what you said
where I think it's probably some sort of
you know setup or kind of trying to
create the feeling of virality and the
fact that that's even a thing is
honestly so weird you know that they'll
try to
come across as being organic I'm not
saying that that is so I've honestly
been a little bit apprehensive of it I
contrast this with uh Miley Cyrus's
flowers which it's it was like a catchy
fun song I guess but it had no kind of
substance to it and also they prepped
its release by basically hinting and
dropping notes on the tabloids like
she's got scandalous stuff in her
personal life you should listen to this
song and so it was big for a little
while because the industry kind of I
don't know had this gross reaction to
like she's had a troubled marriage and
therefore here's this so here's some
consuming right and I'd rather have
something like this that is about values
that's about yeah something whoa I mean
we can criticize we criticize all kinds
of things criticize anything you want to
just because I don't like it doesn't
mean that you know everyone does can't
listen anyways I happen to like this
type of music I also happen to think
this was kind of refreshing I think
people are sort of starved for a little
bit more in their lyrics I think that a
lot of country music Roots were
absolutely kind of centered in that sort
of
theming too you know or however you say
the word but I will add this I've
explained this uh in the previous
segments we talked about with billboard
but we put out some music and the
challenges we face
the music we make and Independent
Artists are making people who are
outside the machine is that
a major label band releases a new album
that label will go to Pandora Spotify
blah blah whatever they'll say even even
new bands they'll say like hey we've got
a new band coming out we want their
songs on this playlist and what will
happen is the Digital streaming playlist
will be like sounds good to us then some
people are hanging out on a Friday night
at their buddy's house they order pizza
and someone's like I'm gonna put on
Pandora and they choose rock and roll or
rock or hard rock or indie rock and then
this new song starts playing they didn't
look for it it's just on the streaming
playlist that band will get a lot of
play and a lot of promotion and if the
song is good then people will share it
put it they'll save it they'll give it a
thumbs up it'll be played more and then
they crack the billboard lists
for Oliver Anthony he had absolutely
none of that it was pure organic support
for his music and enjoyment of his music
that resulted in him hitting this chart
so if uh there there's one band that I
actually really like one of the songs
they put out and it was the weirdest
thing to see someone with less than a
thousand subscribers no music presence
whatsoever gets signed to a label put
out a song that I I liked but no one's
ever heard of the song failed charted
nowhere but it was placed on all of
these major radio stations and playlists
and I'm like that's the machine yeah
someone's behind the screens Oliver
Anthony not only hit number one but he
did it in spite of the fact the industry
desperately tries to keep people like
him out that's what John Rich was saying
if he was signed to a label they never
let the song on the air no way no way
that's how so many things people don't
realize one one hit wonder is because
their music they kept putting out got
put on the shelf and didn't go anywhere
that happens the same way it's but this
is just modern Payola and that's already
illegal it's just not it wasn't caught
we haven't caught up to like streaming
services oh right yeah so yeah so Paola
is basically pay to play yeah it's
illegal that's right it is illegal you
said when you had radios you get up I
think it's so called a mechanical
meaning the rotation of a record but
yeah it's illegal and everything else
except for streaming services but it'll
we'll get there hopefully so there are
people who want to go and say like go to
a radio station say we'll give you x
amount of dollars if you just put our
song on that's illegal oh but now
because they can buy the song and it
accounts for 150 streams is that the
problem uh yes but it's not it's not
illegal on streams right so that's why
it's still illegal to have like you have
what it's called basically a playlist or
who's a person that works for Spotify in
this case and then they choose who your
song makes these playlists I'm sure if
you use Spotify you know what the
playlist if your song makes these
playlists they're like old radio DJs
they were the people who select the
track to play the song it's the same
thing as Paola it's just a modern day
Paola that hasn't we haven't caught up
oh yeah you know that some celebrities
are so big their songs are gonna play no
matter what so let's say you're a major
label and you've got a new band coming
out and you want to make money like hey
look we spent a hundred thousand dollars
on this album we need to make that money
back you can go to these platforms and
just be like hey we would like here we
were we are submitting this to the norm
legal channels please add this to your
you know Digital streaming playlist in
this genre
these these companies know if they say
no then what happens is Major label says
well then I guess there's no real reason
for us to keep insert major label
artists playing on your platform and
then they lose money if that you've got
Apple music you've got title you've got
Spotify you've got Pandora you've got
YouTube music imagine if any one of them
lost a major star that would be like a
form of blackmail if the label is said
to Spotify yeah yeah it's still unspoken
they're implying didn't Taylor Swift
pull her music from some platform on
Spotify for a long time and I wonder
what that was really about I don't know
seriously she wrote a letter about it
yeah she did like re-release her music
wasn't that the case like it was because
well the Spotify thing she said she
didn't like the terms and that she felt
like they weren't paying artists enough
and I haven't read it in a long time
they don't uh so she pulled her music
I'm sure she had her own specific reason
why she was like I'm personally not
making enough money but she represented
as like I'm actually fighting for
everybody uh and then the Masters thing
is something else but it is it is crazy
how little you make I guess is the crazy
thing people don't realize you make
almost nothing even on really big songs
that get money and you were part of you
were on the people like you see a lot of
who wrote the song Whatever you get
included on that and you make nothing I
made nothing when I was working I mean
not enough to survive in my life so yeah
we we uh put out a handful of songs and
we with the few songs we put out we
experimented with different ways to
promote and different ways to to uh like
how we tell people what to do so with
like one song we said hey everyone just
go and buy the song and then we charted
really well now another song where like
hey everyone go listen to the song
listens
don't do anything you make zero dollars
you get nothing and then you are just it
doesn't even matter you can get two
million views plus sales and then three
million views and the sales you get you
you chart you make money streams don't
do anything for anybody nope and
charting is sort of make or breakout
assume for music like that's how you get
like what is if you wanted to support a
local artist was it better to buy their
song on iTunes or is it better to listen
to them 100 times on but here here I'll
simplify it for you are you is is Oliver
Anthony better off with you handing him
one dollar or you taking you giving him
nothing I mean I would assume it's
better to hand him a dollar but I I
guess what I'm coming up to is is it
imperative that artists then go on tour
like if you want to make it as a
musician what do you need to do like
yeah for Oliver Anthony if he peeks at
billboard you know number one that's
awesome but then if he wants to continue
but like he can't survive at number one
like is that gonna make him a living
he's gonna have to tour like what are
the next steps oh yeah yeah that's
that's like the thing if you if you make
money like the idea and the argument for
streaming is that you don't make money
on the stream streaming is essentially
your advertising you're like your
Merchant they're not really you make
money for merchandising Selling Stuff uh
vinyls or clothing or whatever and you
make money from touring which is going
on tour and going to different states
and then make money on the tickets
coming in you don't really make money on
the actual music so if if he wants to be
he's a millionaire overnight yeah
definitely not not because of any of
these stupid deals he shouldn't take
them but because
I imagine all of these festivals are
going to be like we got to get this guy
yeah he's got the biggest song in the
world and right now he can he can charge
whatever whatever he wants because
people want to see him perform and he
deserves it this is this is natural
talents breaking through the machine
yeah I want you to imagine this there is
a bunch of angry suits waving woke signs
and this guy runs full speed with a
sledgehammer spins around and throws it
into a giant TV they're all watching
yeah that's a nice visual
that's kind of how I see it right you
know so more of this this is like the
music version of sound of Freedom we are
breaking through the industry people
keep saying to play it well but we can't
I'm not gonna people should listen to
his song no yeah people should know you
should go to iTunes right now and buy
the song yeah give the man a dollar yeah
if you like it and you support the music
go and buy if you if you've already
heard it and you liked it you didn't go
and buy it like what are you doing what
are you guys think about now because the
age of the recording artists making a
bunch of money is kind of waning you
know it used to be in in the 1900s it
was like the only time in history that
you'd be able to like spend two hours
recording a song and then it you could
sell it for 100 million dollars over the
next 80 years yeah and now you don't
control distribution really and it was a
blip so like is it smart to make your
own music and just let people download
it from your website from you for 99
cents all the money goes right to you
screw iTunes screw Amazon
yeah no charts
all the all the prestige crap just sell
it directly to your people that's
I would say I would say yes but
obviously we want that but the time
being we want to take over the industry
we I want
when young people are looking up to a
musician because they want to be number
one they don't see WAP they see rich men
north of Richmond this is culture
changing this is going to be
inspirational for you for the younger
Generations this also
you've got young people who are skewing
conservative these young men sure fine
they're gonna go that direction no
matter what thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time